[Musique]
le monde se réveille stupéfait devant le
fracas des bombes en europe les chars de
moscou viennent de pénétrer par
centaines sur le territoire ukrainien
vladimir poutine dit vouloir défendre
les républiques séparatistes du dombass
reconnu indépendante
pris la décision de lancer une opération
militaire
mais les forces russes ne se cantonne
pas à l'est du pays le kremlin multiplie
les fronts il prend le contrôle de zone
au nord de kiev mais est très vite
confronté à la pugnacité de la
résistance ukrainienne une résistance
incarné par un homme
il ya beaucoup de fausses informations
sur internet en ce moment en disant à
notre armée de déposer les armes mais
qu'un évacuation est en cours et bien
moi je suis là
la loi martiale est instaurée tous les
hommes de 18 à 60 ans sont appelés à se
battre pour la plupart des autres c'est
l'exode forcé au 20 mars 10 millions
d'ukrainiens quitter leur foyer selon
l'onu une première en europe depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale pour sauver la
capitale ailleurs pin les ukrainiens
détruites même ce pont qui devient le
symbole de la résistance à kharkiv la
deuxième plus grande ville du pays il
repousse petit à petit les forces russes
après des semaines de bombardements les
ukrainiens oblige même les troupes
adverses a reculé près de la frontière
après un mois de combat impossible pour
les russes de prendre la capitale les
forces de moscou se recentre donc sur le
dombass et sur la ville de mario paul
pilonnaient depuis le début de la guerre
est détruite à 90% elle tombe aux mains
russe le 21 avril à l'exception du site
métallurgique d'obstacles
depuis les sous sols de la syrie des
centaines de soldats d'ukrainiens
résiste aux 86e jours de guerre ils
finissent par se rendre à l'armée russe
une armée russe accusé de crimes de
guerre avec son repli du nord de kiev 20
mars elle laisse derrière elle les
horreurs des massacres de civils dans
les rues de boudhha les images de
dizaines de cadavres d'habitants exécuté
choc le monde entier lundi le premier
soldat russe jugée en ukraine pour
crimes de guerre a été reconnu coupable
et condamné à la prison à perpétuité
pour le meurtre d'un civil